two years into the pandemic what's
happening in hong kong looks more like
the first two months
patients wheeled out onto the street as
hospital capacity is overwhelmed
the city's dynamic zero covert strategy
is failing and it's bracing for the
worst
as far as hong kong is concerned we need
to find our own way out of this epidemic
it has
outgrown our capacity
hong kong has been closed off from the
world since the start of the pandemic it
had done well as a result recording just
over 200 deaths with a series of partial
lockdowns and restrictions on gatherings
the city bought itself time but it did
not spend it well ahead of omicron's
arrival
the vaccination rate among the elderly
is very low
and hospitals have been overwhelmed
because mild and even asymptomatic
covert cases must be sent there
they actually don't need any medical uh
health
but um people who are just panicking
they are panicking because um because
there are so many of them
thousands
so we could not we just could not
accommodate them in the hospitals
hong kong has trod a middle path between
the western and chinese approaches to
lockdown
now it seems to have the worst of both
worlds and we'll have to choose one
definitively
chinese president xi jinping has made a
rare public statement to order that the
overriding mission for hong kong's
leaders is to stabilize the outbreak
that suggests the ultra strict lockdowns
of the mainland may be enforced on the
city as the western world emerges from
the coveted storm hong kong is right in
its middle tom cheshire sky news beijing